♪ ♪ ♪
- Une région éparg
les combats, mais sur un pied
de guerre.
130 kilomètres du Bélarus, un
voisin allié de l'ennemi russe.
sérieux. Voici les dernières
recrues du bataillon de Lubart,
des jeunes, pour la plupart
sans expérience militaire.
On les sent nerveu Déjà soudés a
guerre, unis devant la Russie.
Des patriotes pas toujours bien
équipés. Entraînés durant
quelquesenvoyés au front. D'auts
resteront ici. La base arrière
doit aussi être défendue.
Il y a une autre raison pour
s'entrainent. C'est que
ce secteur de l'Ukraine il est
stratégique pour les pays
de l'OTAN qui livrent des armes
Une partie des armes passent par
la région et par les routes
qui sont ici.
Le commandant rap à côté;
c'est par ici que l'aide
étrangère peut arriver à Kiev
le plus directement possible.
Ce bataillon s'est jours après .
Ses membres sont prêts à tout
pour empêcher l'Ukraine d'être
morcelée par la Russie.
Le commandant promet que
l'ennemi sera anéanti sur
le champ s'il ose franchir
Même confiance dans un hôtel
de villeé, où nous
reçoit un jeune maire fatigué
et très occupé.
Les défenses ont été installées
interdit de les montrer. Ce sont
des points de contrôles bi
surveillés, parfois imposants.
en appui aux soldats
et policiers ukrainiens;
des gens qui préfèrent souvent
ne pas être filmés.
visibles dans cette ville,
un peu comme ces a
au patriotisme, des rappels
que les énergies doivent aller
Mais le maire reconnaît que
la population est inquiète
la frappe de missiles russescett
un dépôt pétrolier.
Ce hangar, c'est un théâtrilleni
d'ordinaire l'ont convertien cet
de la nourriture, du matériel
médical, militairelà, on les
envoie directement au front.
Ce midi, on prépare un convoi
pour Mikolaïv, une ville
assiégée par les forces russes.
Génératrices, drones de
surveillance, munitions et
médicaments, vêteravitailleravil
pour entretenir la résistance
ukrainienne.
Le tout, distribué grâce
à une p un peu partout
en Ukraine.
Les préc à des c à des c à des s
expérimentés, parfois guidés
par des soldats ukrainiens pour
naviguer dans les zones les plus
risquées
La ville de Marioue
inaccessible à ce réseau,
un crève-coeur pour cette femme
Des artistes engagés, toute
une ville dévouée
des compatriotes qui sont
au front.
Chaque fement des policiers
résume ce qui doit être
à l'esprit de tous ici.e faire "
Ici Yanik Dumont-Baron,
Radio-Canada, Lou